in the world of demon slayer the most
talented warriors have a chance to
develop a mysterious tattoo or a scar
these tattoos are referred to as demon
slayer marks each mark looks unique
relating to the breathing style of the
bearer in this video we'll explain how
every hashida awakened the mark and
which powers they gained from it the
true origin of the demon slayer marks
are unknown however the first recorded
occurrence of these markings was in the
sengoku era and the first ever bearer
was none other than yorichi tsugikuni
who for unknown reasons was born with a
demon slayer mark besides him almost
every single swordsman during the
sengoku era awakened their mark as well
upon awakening the mark the user is
granted super human strength speed and
enhanced breathing techniques beyond
that of a normal breath user their
strength and speed could even rival that
of the strongest demons such as the
upper ranks of the 12 kazuki although
the demon's lair mark grants users many
different abilities by far the strongest
one is bright red nicholas sword
everyone activates this technique
differently for tanjido and yorici it
naturally activates when they are
engaging in combat on the other hand
muichiro and omanai managed to turn
their swords red by focusing all of
their strength into their grip and
lastly sanami and gyome managed to
achieve this with friction by clashing
their weapons apart from red ninja and
sword those with demon slayer mark are
fully able to access the transparent
world a person that possesses this
ability becomes able to see the muscles
blood flow and joint movement in living
beings allowing the user to accurately
predict and react to their opponent's
movements as well as confirm the health
and well-being of others with this
ability yoduchi was able to locate
muzan's seven hearts and five brains
tanjiro was able to decapitate akazan
and gyome was able to stand his ground
against kokushibo with all that being
said transparent world is surely one of
the most powerful abilities gained by
those with mark but all this power comes
at a great cost swordsmen who have
awakened the demon slayer mark are
destined to die upon reaching the age of
25. kokoshibu mentioned that it reduces
their lifespan due to the strain on
their bodies in a conversation muichuro
had with guillemet guillaume describes
the curse's effect as paying one's
lifespan in advance in the exchange for
a greater physique it is still possible
to awaken the mark after a demon slayer
is older than 25 evident in guilleme's
case who was 27 years old he managed to
activate the mark and receive the
benefits without dying immediately
kokushibu surmised that due to his
unique situation guillaume would die
within a few hours of activating it
though kokushibu's prediction came true
it is now known if gyome's death was a
result of the curse or his injuries from
the final battle against muzan so how
many known demon slayers managed to
awaken their mark the first one is of
course yorichi the original creator of
breathing styles he was born with it
possessing the tremendous physical
abilities granted by its effects
throughout his entire lifespan being the
first person ever with demon slayer mark
yorichi was by far the strongest human
to ever exist he was the only person to
ever pose a serious threat to the demon
king muzan during his fight against
muzan yorichi was able to gain instant
advantage and even perform his special
13th sun breathing form he was inches
away from killing the demon king and was
the only man in history to do so all by
himself unlike all other mark users in
his era yoruchi was able to defy fate
and live to about 85 years of age it is
a complete mystery as to why yorichi was
immune to mark's effects but it's
presumably because he was the first one
ever to have it and born with it
naturally unlike all other mark bearers
who must train to attain it another
marked demon slayer from the sengoku era
is michikatsu tsugikuni also known as
pokushibo before he became a demon he
was a twin brother of yoruji tsugikuni
and also the second strongest demon
slayer to ever exist michikatsu's main
motivation was to become stronger than
his brother and therefore he joined the
demon slayer corps so that he could
train alongside him not long after that
he awakened his demon slayer mark
similar to yorichi michikatsu awakened
the transparent world which he used with
great proficiency and was even able to
identify that muichiro was his
descendant simply by looking at him now
onto our protagonist tanjiro kamado not
many people know this but tanjiro had
the demon slayer mark all along this is
due to him and his family being closely
tied with sun breathing as all sun
breathing users have demon slayer marks
the scar on his forehead is actually a
hidden demon slayer mark that was yet to
develop into a fully transformed mark
after the hashida training arc his scar
is replaced with a permanent flame mark
and when he activates his demon slayer
mark it grows in size interestingly
enough tanjido's mark is exactly the
same as the marks of yorichi and
kokushibo tanjido awakens his mark for
the first time while fighting upper rank
6 gyotero which granted him the arm
strength needed to behead the demon he
later awakened it again while unleashing
the dragon sun halo head dance against
kantengu's clones later the mark
reappears during his rematch against
upper rank 3. akaza the drawback to his
mark state is that tanjiro can only
enter it on rare occasions and he can
only use it for a very short period
since it causes exhaustion to his body
as proven in all of his battles against
the upper ranks tanjido first unlocked
the bright red sword ability with the
help of nezuko she lit his sword on fire
using her pyrokinetic blood demon art
which gave him an edge over hantengu's
clones and drastically slowed down their
regenerative abilities after mastering
the sun breathing tangential gains the
ability to turn his nichiren sword
bright red all by himself he later
managed to do it one final time with the
help of giu to drive muzan into a corner
and hamper his instantaneous
regeneration like his father he gained
the ability to foresee the opponent's
attacks by analyzing and perceiving his
opponent's blood flow muscles and joint
alignment in this state his movement
intuition and evasion speed increased
dramatically he accessed the state by
remembering his father's words and used
it in the midst of battle to defeat
akaza although he has also learned how
to use it he is not completely
proficient in it as shown when he had
trouble perceiving it during his fight
against muzan another young demon slayer
that was able to unlock his demon slayer
mark is muichiro tokito muichiro is the
youngest person ever to become a hashira
being only 14 years old he played a
major role in defeating upper rank 5
yoko at swordsmith village after
escaping from the water prison that
gyoko trapped him in muichiro's memories
of his past all came back the anger over
his brother's death manifests into his
demon slayer mark his speed and
abilities dramatically increased as he
goes into the shed and attacks gyoko
gyoko retaliates with his blood demon
art and muichiro's blade breaks trying
to cut it prompting kozo to quickly hand
him his new one he then goes on and uses
missed breathing fifth form sea of
clouds and haze landing a blow on
gyoko's neck gyoko tries using another
blood demon art but muichiro easily
counters it with misbreathing slicing
the head of the demon's molt as he
escapes to a tree upper rank 5 then
transforms into his real form becoming
vastly stronger the two engage each
other again gyoko using his blood demon
art and muichiro responding with the
form he personally developed missed
breathing seventh form obscuring clouds
when gyoko tries to find him in a sea of
mist muijito effortlessly decapitates
him defeating an upper moon and only 14
years of age however after the fight his
mark vanishes and he immediately begins
to suffer from the effects of the poison
showing that the mark is only effective
for as long as it is manifested another
hashida that plays a major role in the
swordsmith village arc is mitsuri she is
the love hashira and even though she
looks like a helpless girl don't let the
looks fool you she's one of the
strongest swordsmen in the series at
swordsmith village when tanjido is
swallowed by one of zohaku-ten's tree
dragons mitsuri slices the creature's
head in half carrying tanjido on her
back safely mitsuti continues to battle
against zohaku-ten dodging his attacks
and countering with love breathing the
demon realizes that she is too fast and
is keeping up with his attacks and as a
response he uses blood demon art
countless striking trees lashing out
many wooden dragons mitsuti becomes a
bit nervous at how wide-ranged it is and
questions if she can get past it with
some effort she manages to get past the
attack and comes very close to
zohaku-ten the demon opens his mouth
confusing mitsuti though she brushes it
off and goes for his neck tangido yells
to her that he is not the real body and
he will not die if his head is cut off
the love hashira realizes her mistake
and is fiercely hit by zuhaku-ten's
compressed sound waves she loses
consciousness and slumps before the
upper rank while being in a coma mitsuti
had unconsciously awakened and obtained
her demon slayer mark which takes the
form of two hearts upside down and
opposite from each other with angel
wings on both sides once she regains
consciousness mitsuti engages zuhakuten
once again she gained a lot of power and
speed by awakening her demon slayer mark
and she managed to keep zuhaku-ten busy
while tanjiro defeated the main body
during the final battle in the infinity
castle demon slayer marks played a big
part in hashida's fight against upper
moons wandering through the castle
tanjuro and giu ran into none other than
upper rank 3 akaza himself as geo
attacks he immediately uses water
breathing impressing akaza as it had
been 50 years since he ran into someone
as good as gyu he uses his destructive
death sending a flurry of punches that
produce giant shock waves at giu which
he negates using his own creation water
breathing 11th form dead calm not long
after giu is sent flying away by one of
akaza's kicks yu soon returns angry and
finally manifests a demon slayer mark as
he begins to engage akaza again akaza
immediately matches guild's new speed
and eventually gains the upper hand
breaking giu's blade with a punch as
akazak closes in for the final blow his
hand is cut off by tanjiro mid attack
saving you you then re-engages akasa
once more but is eventually defeated
when akaza's final form breaks through
his dead calm technique yu then watches
as akaza is beheaded by tanjido this
fight is very interesting as we got to
see how strong upper moon 3 really is as
well as how the demon slayer mark may
not be enough to defeat some of the
upper moons somewhere else in the
infinity castle muichiro and genya were
about to die at the hands of upper moon
1 kokushibu suddenly genya's brother
sanemi rescues him by reflecting the
upper rank's attack with his wind
breathing kokushibu makes his distance
and sees that the win hashia has come in
his presence the two then start their
intense duel as both of their swords
clash kokushibu uses the moon breathing
forcing him to backstep away from the
attack sanomi is confused as to how so
many slashes are appearing even when the
upper rank isn't swinging his blade
sanemi counters his attack with the wind
breathing and kokushibu praises both
sonomy and his attacks for being at
their absolute peak sonomy thinks to
himself that he cannot stop getting
goosebumps at kokushibu's overall powers
and skill kokushibu eventually
overpowers senemy knocking him back and
decimating the surrounding landscape
wounding him heavily just as it seemed
that sanomi was about to die he was
saved by guilleme as sanomi goes to
stitch himself up gyome starts
exchanging blows with upper mood as the
battle progresses you may reveal that he
too has awakened his mark appearing as
cracked earth fissure-like patterns on
both of his forearms when awakened it
drastically increases his physical
abilities such as his strength allowing
him to stand his ground against
kokushibu for some time gilmei goes on
to use many of his stone breathing
techniques all in an attempt to gain
some advantage over the upper moon
meanwhile sanomi who was able to patch
up his injuries also awakens his demon
slayer mark that resembled a single
paper origami windmill that is green in
color with two dots on both sides on his
right cheek the mark dramatically
increases his physical capabilities as
seen when sonemy was still able to fight
and contend with kokoshibu despite being
grievously injured however even though
his physical endurance strength and
tolerance to pain dramatically increased
xanami couldn't land a significant hit
on kokushibu without assistance from
gyome and muichiro it took all three
hashidas with all their power combined
to finally defeat the upper rank 1. it's
safe to assume that without the powers
of the marks the demon slayers would
stand no chance against kokushibu and
would be killed very quickly later on
during the final battle against muzan
obanai also awakened his own demon
slayer mark his demon slayer mark took
the form of three snake-like tattoo
patterns the mark boosted all of iguro's
natural abilities as seen when he was
able to land powerful sword slashes
against muzan swiftly dodge and maneuver
himself to avoid all of his immensely
fast attacks and increase his physical
stamina and durability allowing him to
fight despite being severely injured
after remembering how muichiro turned
his blade red obani puts all of his
strength into gripping his blade turning
it bright red however he put too much
strength into his grip and almost
fainted due to the lack of oxygen
turning his niche in sword bright red
proved to be extremely effective against
muzan allowing his attacks to hamper his
immediate regeneration check out this
video where we explained all future
hashidas in the demon slayer core what
are you waiting for click it